a united european front
against the strongman in belarus
eu leaders reject the re-election of
alexander lukashenko
siding firmly with his opponents despite
the risk of angering russia
the eu will impose shortly sanctions
on a substantial number of individuals
responsible for violence
repression and election throat
we call on the belarusian authorities to
find a peaceful way out of the crisis
by ending by ending the violence
lithuania's president a leading voice
supporting opponents of the regime
you said that alexander lukashenko is no
longer the legitimate president
the eu is now imposing new sanctions
and yet he remains in power supported by
president
vladimir putin what next
i believe that pressure from the
international community in one way or
another
will make an impact on belarus and they
will start talking to their people
and looking for a solution to the
current situation
because escalation of the conflict and
even strong repression against peaceful
people
could lead to a very negative result for
the regime itself
lithuania is harbouring the main
opposition leader
who spoke out earlier honorable leaders
of europe
i call on you to support the awakening
of belarus
i call on all countries to respect the
principles of
international law but the embattled
leaders standing firm
despite days of protests he's got strong
external backers too
not just russia but china as well
evidence his police are cracking down
again on dissent
this pair spent 10 days in jail for
playing a well-known protest song at a
pro-regime event
they're out now but are still scared
the feeling is if someone is watching us
surely we also wind ourselves up
but there is no feeling of complete
innocence there is a feeling that at any
moment we
yet still there are those who dare to
strike and protest
factory workers lending their voice to
the call for change
debrahim sky news vilnius